(tense tonal music)
- [Narrator] This is an artist
painting a portrait of a cat.
She wasn't hired by this cat's owner,
but by Chewy, the online pet supply store.
The company has set out tens of thousands
of these surprise pet portraits
over the past eight years.
And during the pandemic,
Chewy customers have shared
them across social media.
The same time, the company's
business has been booming.
In 2020, Chewy gained over 5
1/2 million active customers.
- We took action pretty quickly,
actually, in our opinion,
and the strategy looking
back was really communicate,
innovate and persevere.
- [Narrator] Here's how Chewy
seized the pandemic pet craze
and ignited investor enthusiasm.
And why some analysts think
its success is built to last.
When the pandemic took hold in 2020,
millions of people were
forced to work from home
and with more time on their
hands, they adopted new pets.
Analysts estimate that
more than 11 million pets
found new homes during the pandemic.
And while pet owners were stuck at home,
many turned to the
internet to buy supplies.
According to a recent report,
consumers bought 30% of their pet food
and supplies online last
year, up from 23% in 2019.
This added up to about $5 billion increase
in online pet spending.
Laurent Schenk,
who analyzes the pet
industry for Morgan Stanley,
says this increase was a
big benefit for retailers.
- We do believe that the pet
industry is better positioned
than some other e-commerce categories
to retain the gains that it saw in 2020
given the sticky-like nature
of not only the product in pet food,
but also the customers themselves
which tend to be very loyal
to specific retailers.
- [Narrator] With the
influx of new pet owners,
retailers like Target and Amazon
all gained more shoppers
over the past year.
But sitting at the top
of the dog pile? Chewy.
Morgan Stanley says the company
has the #1 market share
position for online pet retail.
- Chewy has performed exceptionally well
during the pandemic,
obviously a beneficiary of the shift
from offline to online as
it relates to e-commerce.
But they also benefited
from the structural
increase in pet ownership.
- [Narrator] But Chewy's
success wasn't just timing.
Analysts say it had a lot to do
with how management at the company
handled the demand from
the pandemic pet boom.
When COVID-19 first first took
hold in the US in March 2020,
Chewy, like many other companies,
was overwhelmed with orders.
The surge in e-commerce demand
strained postal services
and this caused week-long delays
that put even more pressure on retailers.
Sumit Singh, the CEO of Chewy,
explains how this impacted his company.
- When industry-wide supply
chains were disrupted,
what was going on was that
we weren't receiving products
optimally across the fulfillment center.
Number two, because fulfillment
center backlog was so high,
typically we deliver product
between one and two days
to customers reliably.
Our shipping times went
up to seven to 10 days.
- [Narrator] Competitors like
Amazon faced similar issues.
But at this key moment, Chewy
made strategic decisions.
To handle the increase in demand,
it hired thousands of new workers
while protecting shipments
for its core subscription customers.
The company also invested
in shipping packages by air
to ensure timely delivery.
- Across a combination of
these three mechanisms,
we were able to sort of
control our situation.
- [Narrator] While these
investments were expensive,
Schenk says they were the right move.
- For businesses that can
retain these customers,
which we think Chewy can,
this should ultimately pay off dividends
over the course of the next several years.
- [Narrator] Over the past year,
Chewy rolled out a number of new products
with a focus on pet health.
In October, the company released
its own pet telehealth service
called Connect with a Vet.
The company's CEO says
the platform was launched
in response to the demand for vet care
while clinics were impacted
by global shutdowns.
- We internally said, "Okay,
how about we develop a solution
"that allows us to connect
customers and veterinarians
"in a time of crisis?"
And we did exactly that.
- [Narrator] Chewy continued
to lean into its healthcare business.
The company announced that
it would be manufacturing
its own compounded medications,
which analysts say is a
competitive advantage.
But rolling out new products is expensive
and this cut into Chewy's profits.
Analysts say these product investments,
along with other
pandemic-related expenses,
are part of why the company
has yet to show an annual profit.
- Any time you make an investment, yes,
you're committing to
generating a healthy return
over the longterm.
And we are very longterm focused.
As it incidentally happens,
this particular service,
Connect with a Vet, yes, it
is currently a cost center
because we're not monetizing it.
It's free for customers.
- [Narrator] Still,
analysts say some investors
have concerns.
- One of the things that investors
have also been a little
bit concerned about
is the fact that Chewy's
flow-through has been smaller,
lighter than some other
e-commerce retailer's experience
during the pandemic,
and I think part of that reason
was the incremental cleaning
costs and the shipping costs,
but also the fact that they did open
a new distribution center.
- [Narrator] The company's
stock saw pullback
over recent weeks.
- The cost that we've invested
in the health and safety
of our team members,
we are not looking to roll
those costs back 100%.
We believe 80% of those costs
will actually remain in network in 2021.
Once inventory balances are
better in check and controlled,
we believe that logistics costs
and inventory freight fulfillment costs
and all of that stuff
will actually start becoming
a little less of a concern.
- [Narrator] Despite
challenges during the pandemic,
analysts say the future of
the company looks positive.
On March 30th,
Chewy reported its first
quarterly net profit ever
along with a 47% increase
in sales over the past year.
Analysts expect Chewy to
have its first full year
of profitability in 2021.
But they say that it's rate of
growth will likely slow down.
- This was a major structural shift
in e-commerce penetration
that is, we think,
unlikely to revert.
So we do think 2021
e-commerce growth decelerates
versus what we saw in 2020,
but we don't think you actually give back
any of the share shift.
So we think this is
structural, this is permanent.
- [Narrator] Experts say the growth
e-commerce companies like
Chewy have experienced
are likely to be the most significant
and lasting effects of the pandemic
on the pet care industry.
(tense tonal music)